♪ ♪
>> WE ARE HAVING A FEW TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES WITH THE LINKS WITH
HARRIS FAULKNER.
IN THIS NEW NORMAL WEAR A IN
TRUTH I’M JONATHAN HUNT NOW,
STEPPING IN FOR HARRIS.
I WANT TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH HOUSE MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY.
HE IS BACK WITH US, AS YOU CAN
SEE, FROM THE NORTH LAWN OF THE
WHITE HOUSE.
MR. McCARTHY, THIS IS A
DIFFICULT SITUATION FOR EVERY
BUSINESS, OBVIOUSLY, ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
IS THERE A SENSE, THOUGH, THAT
THE WRONG BUSINESSES ARE GETTING
THE MONEY FROM THIS STIMULUS?
WE’VE SEEN THESE BIG BUSINESSES
WHICH COULD WE HAVE MILLIONS AND
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE BANK,
AND SOME VERY SMALL BUSINESSES
SAYING, "WE’RE NOT SEEING
ANYTHING."
>> WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
ACCOUNTABILITY, ANY TIME, STOPS.
LATEST NUMBERS, WE FIND MORE
THAN 74% OF THE 349 BILLION THAT
HAVE GONE OUT HAS GONE TO SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT HAS $60,000
IN PAYROLL OR LESS.
I HAVE PERSONAL STORIES FROM MY
OWN HOME TOWN OF SMALL
BUSINESSES CALLING ME, THINKING,
BECAUSE THEY
WERE ABLE TO BRING PEOPLE BACK
THEY HAVE LAID OFF.
I KNOW THERE’S 700,000 MORE
SMALL BUSINESSES SITTING OUT
THERE THAT NEED A LOAN, AND
THOSE THAT STILL HAVE TO APPLY.
WE WERE ABLE TO MOVE THE
EQUIVALENT OF WHAT THE SBA HAS
DONE FOR 14 YEARS, IN 14 DAYS.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
ACCOUNTABILITY, THOSE WHO HAVE
GONE THROUGH AND DONE SOMETHING
WRONG IN THE SYSTEM, THEY GIVE
THAT BACK.
THAT’S WHAT THE SECRETARY OF
TREASURY IS DOING.
I WAS JUST TALKING TO HIM AND
THE PRESIDENT ABOUT THIS, AND
THEY ARE MAKING SURE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY, IF SOMEONE DOES
SOMETHING OR NOT, WE WANT TO
BRING THAT BACK.
THIS IS DESIGNED ONLY FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
>> Jonathan: CONGRESSMAN, IF I
COULD SWITCH TO ANOTHER SUBJECT,
WE ARE SEEING MORE AND MORE
PROTESTS POPPING UP ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AGAINST THE CONTINUED
CLOSURE OF THE AMERICAN ECONOMY.
DEMONSTRATORS CALLING FOR THOSE
LOCKDOWNS TO BE LIFTED.
IN SOME CASES, IT SEEMS TO ME,
THE DEMONSTRATORS ARE NOT
OBEYING THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
LAWS.
ARE THEY DOING THE RIGHT THING
BY THE WRONG THING, HERE?
>> EVERYBODY HAS THE RIGHT TO
PROTEST.
YOU SHOULD PROTEST IN A MANNER
WHERE YOU HAVE SOCIAL
DISTANCING.
WE SHOULD ALSO HAVE PLANS FOR
HOW WE OPEN THE COUNTRY BACK UP.
THAT’S GOING TO BE DIFFERENT BY
STATE, BY COUNTY, AND THAT’S
WHERE WE NEED TO WORK TOGETHER.
I SENT A LETTER TO
SPEAKER PELOSI, I TALKED TO HER
FOR MORE THAN AN HOUR TODAY, ON
IDEAS WHERE WE CAN START TO OPEN
UP CONGRESS, AS WELL.
YOU DON’T WANT TO OPEN IT ALL AT
ONCE, YOU WANT TO PHASE IN, FROM
COMMITTEES AND OTHERS.
WE WANT TO DO IN A HEALTHY, SAFE
MANNER, JUST AS YOU CAN DO
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
EVERY AREA WILL BE DIFFERENT.
THAT’S WHY WE WANT TO WORK
TOGETHER AND, AT ALL TIMES, EVEN
WHAT HE OPENS BACK UP, YOU WANT
TO KEEP THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING.
WE KNOW A LOT MORE ABOUT THIS
VIRUS THEN WE KNEW MORE THAN
EVEN A MONTH AGO.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT IT DIDN’T COME
FROM HERE, BUT WE ARE GOING TO
DEFEAT THIS TOGETHER.
LET’S ALL
WORK TOGETHER IN THAT MANNER AND
OVERCOME WHATEVER
OBSTACLES WE SEE.
>> Jonathan: HAS MINORITY
LEADER KEVIN MCCARTHY, STAY WITH
US.
YOU, I, AND THE REST OF THE
WORLD WILL BE HAPPY TO KNOW THAT
HARRIS FAULKNER IS BACK WITH US.
I FIND IT BACK TO YOU, HARRIS.
>> Harris: [LAUGHS]
JONATHAN, I APPRECIATE THAT.
IT WAS GREAT TO COHOST WITH YOU
FOR A COUPLE OF SECONDS.
TO THE MINORITY LEADER, YOU ARE
THE MOST PATIENT PERSON ON THE
PLANET TODAY, SO THANK YOU.
TECHNOLOGICALLY, WE ARE BACK
TOGETHER.
I WANT TO STEP BACK FOR A
SECOND.
I WAS ABLE TO WATCH, COULDN’T
HEAR ALL OF IT.
THOSE PART OF THE PROBLEM.
LET’S TALK ABOUT THOSE COMPANIES
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT, WHO
GAINED ACCESS TO SOME OF THAT
SMALL BUSINESS LOAN MONEY.
THE NUMBERS ARE PRETTY
STAGGERING.
DMC GLOBAL, IT WAS IN EXCESS OF
$100 MILLION.
LET’S JUST CALL IT.
RECEIVING AID, HAVING MARKET
VALUES, THESE WERE BIG
COMPANIES.
FIESTA RESTAURANT GROUP AND SOME
OTHERS.
IS THERE ANY SORT OF PUNITIVE
THING YOU CAN DO TAX WISE ON THE
BACK?
LOOK, THEY FOLLOWED THE
LEGISLATION THOUGH IT WAS
WRITTEN, I GET THAT, BUT THEY
HAD TO HAVE KNOWN, "REALLY, I’M
GOING TO GET THIS MUCH MONEY
BACK?"
SHAKE SHACK GIVING HER
$10 MILLION BACK.
THE SOMETHING ON THE BACK END IF
THEY DON’T GIVE IT BACK THAT YOU
MIGHT TEXT THEM AT A HIGHER RATE
FOR A PERIOD OF TIME TO RECOUP
SOME OF THAT?
WHAT’S BEING TALKED ABOUT TO
MAKE IT FAIR?
>> WE WILL GIVE THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GIVE IT BACK.
IT WAS NOT DESIGNED FOR THOSE
COMPANIES TO BE ABLE TO ACQUIRE
THIS MONEY.
THIS IS DESIGNED FOR BUSINESSES,
SMALL BUSINESS.
500 OR FEWER.
AS YOU TALK ABOUT THAT MONEY
THAT WENT OUT TO THEM,
OVERWHELMINGLY THE MONEY WENT TO
THE RIGHT PEOPLE.
THE CHALLENGE WAS IT IS SO
POPULAR -- REMEMBER WHAT WE’RE
DOING, WE ARE DEALING WITH
SOMETHING IN A CRISIS, CREATING
THESOMETHING WE HAVEN’T BEFORE.
HE LOOKED TO THE BUSINESSES THAT
HAVE A PAYROLL LESS THAN 60,000,
AND WHAT IT’S DESIGNED TO DO IS
PAY PEOPLE.
TO KEEP PEOPLE EMPLOYED, EVEN
ONE GOVERNMENT TOLD YOU YOUR
BUSINESS NEEDS TO BE SHUT DOWN.
MORE THAN 60% OF THOSE MONEY
WENT OUT FROM SMALL BANKS, BANKS
THAT HAD $10 BILLION OR LESS IN
ASSETS.
REMEMBER, WE STARTED WITH 1800
BANKS, AND I WERE OVER 5,000.
OVERWHELMINGLY, THIS PROGRAM IS
WORKING.
THAT’S WHY MORE PEOPLE ARE
APPLYING.
IF YOU ARE IN AND SINCE HE WENT
THROUGH THAT YOU SHOULDN’T HAVE
GOTTEN THIS MONEY, WE’LL GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY, BECAUSE
AMERICA SHOULD COME TOGETHER AND
WORK TOGETHER.
GIVE THAT BACK TO WHAT IT’S
INTENDED FOR.
>> Harris: HOW MUCH TIME DO
THEY HAVE TO GIVE IT BACK?
>> Harris: TALKING TO THE
PRESIDENT, THEY HAVE A VERY
SHORT TIME PEOPLE TO IT BACK.
I KNOW WE WILL.
>> Harris: [LAUGHS]
OKAY.
GOOD TO SEE YOU TODAY.